good morning Chris how are you happy
holidays to you by the way Chris has
sent me a text last night and it was a
picture of a print ad that we did for
dandruff Head & Shoulders a Head &
Shoulders dandruff commercial yeah I
remember when we were shooting that it's
Tirico and Chris McKendree you and me
and exactly my wife's came across it I
had had dinner with Chris and Mike Reiss
you're the only one in this thing of the
head or shoulders club from 1990
whatever that was but I look like
Gulliver in there I look so big compared
to certainly Tirico and Chris McKendree
I like my allegedly hip anchor would
wear below the belt under a blazer yeah
but we always you know there were times
when we just threw on whatever I put on
warm-up pants sometimes when I did
Sports Center and I think who busted us
somebody wore shorts one time and there
was a camera angle shot on the side and
then all of a sudden that ruined for
everybody you know you had to wear full
suits now when you went on sports in
yeah how many years have you been there
32 no what's my reaction
what's the closest you ever came to
going to leaving ESPN get like a right I
just curious you looked around your
contract is up you look around at the
time I didn't have what I would consider
my dream gig which I have now that's a
favorite sports championship events and
so you know it everybody goes through
scientists I'm sure to company for that
long you're gonna go through times where
you're wondering if you're at the right
place and you're gonna look around and
see what's out there it doesn't it
Ellis's to leverage a better deal so I
mean there were certainly there's a
moment with CBS there where I felt
pretty close but I think in anything in
life you know you know this you don't
run away from something you run towards
something better
and it really wasn't anything better at
the time so very very very happy I
didn't make that mistake but yeah no way
a place for three decades it doesn't
cross your mind hey wonder what else is
out there and that's what I've told
people at ESPN because they saw what I
did or I've done and then they go hey
I'm curious about that and I I say don't
don't run away from ESPN run to
something that you truly want to do so
the advice that you give yourself is the
advice I give to some of these people at
the mothership I just say we've all seen
you've done damage there's a cautionary
tale for everybody all right we have a
quite a game-day question here this is a
Chris Fowler joining us right the former
host of College GameDay if Reese Davis
somehow can't answer the bell on game
day who is the guy that they go to to
bring it first of all you have to answer
the bell and game day you can't not
answer the bell there's no throwing in
the towel there's no sitting on the
stool so hey I took a body shot like
Canelo's upon with you and I'm just
going to go to one knee and tap out that
doesn't work so these will never tap out
he will always be there so that the
premise is shaky but I've seen a
different city than game day so it
doesn't really work we're not synced up
that often where the a PC game is in the
same place that's why Kirk has to make
that that mad - yeah man who do you go
where if you got to go to the bullpen
let's just say most extremely well I
think Reese is an Iron Man yeah but if
you happen to be like a puddle jumper
away man okay
I'm enjoying what I'm doing I like
sleeping in on Saturdays - I really do I
like having a Friday night in the
college town more importantly so I can't
sleep in the most I never get to go out
on Friday nights at college sounds okay
you're at the hotel grinding when you
host that show and so now I know what
it's like
oh it's what's going on inside a night
in Tuscaloosa in Ann Arbor and
we can have a real meal and a couple
beverages and sleep in what would be the
most dangerous college town on a Friday
places that don't have two o'clock
closing late life all right I got a
question here for you and yeah there's
it's two questions I want you to argue
for the four team playoff and then I
want you to argue for the eight team
playoff which one do you want to pick
first
well the argument for the four team
playoff was that when it was first you
know it was a big improvement over the
BCS the shortcomings are there I guess
the argument for it is that you you feel
like you have a good chance to have
three competitive playoff games in a
scene play out I think is inevitable and
it was only a matter of time but
conferences like the big ten start
getting excluded so Jim Delaney
the idea before all those conference
commissioners do not want any team
playoffs until they start getting left
out self interest comes in and I
understand that there's a business of
strengthening and enhancing their own
league not not the overall sport so when
it's bad for the Big Ten debe 14 in
class let's go to eight same thing for
the pac-12 in other conferences they get
excluded so I think it's headed in that
direction
how you implemented that the Devils in
the details I don't think you could just
keep adding games and I don't like to
use well in high school they play 1516
games and so do they the lower division
ring the siphons playoff games around 15
for Bannon Georgia last year for example
I mean just to add another game on
doesn't make sense it and ask yourself
this it's it's really about opportunity
and optics to go to eight now you're
going to get all the power five
champions and that's the only way it's
ever going to happen politically you're
going to get five conference in but just
be a group of five you get two at-large
so you're going to get to essence each
and every year out of the eight you can
get that that other at-large scene the
second day
10-team our second big 12 or if ECC ever
had to quality teams again you know but
but that's what you're looking at and
then you're gonna look at for
quarterfinal games probably at campus
site so who is going to go into
Tuscaloosa and win a playoff game or go
to Death Valley Clemson I mean it's
possible but is it likely don't you
think a lot of years you'd have the
scene for teams and the semi that you
would have had anyway in a fourteen
playoff like I said it's it's about it's
about the possibilities and the
opportunities and I think you'll get
there I think the opportunity is the key
that that it's just like March Madness I
don't I don't want to take away from the
regular season March Madness is take it
away from the regular season it's you
know pretty much moot to me but the
regular season in college football if I
got rid of the conference championship
games and I did have these you know
quarterfinal games I think that college
football would have owned they would own
a couple of weekends here as opposed to
you know oh by the way we're gonna come
up for air in a couple of weeks and we
got a couple of bowl games for you that
you know for the last about that no one
really saw the sport overall making wise
this is what's better for the game and
it's little bit that way and it's not
going to be that way probably but there
are weeks in a regular season in college
football where the schedules are
incredibly weak I saw some Saturday's
this season that are the worst I've ever
seen because there is no central control
of scheduling the SEC plays virtual buys
against the FCS teams and it takes kind
of a breather for their starters so they
can get ready for the rivalry games it's
done so widely now I tell you don't
worth complaining about anymore just a
part of the sport but I think you have
to get rid of a conference championship
games here that was my point man would
you go to a you know you don't need to
have those games yes you see is really
the only copper temperature being the
series you're out is a sellout and it
kind of like captivates fans across the
conference the other conference
matter to the to fan bases that are
involved but that's it
and I think if you get rid of those yeah
it would cost the SEC some money that's
one of their crown jewels but you'd make
up for it by having a whole pile of cash
and a virtual guarantee I having two two
teams in the class areas
so I think that that would have to
happen and I don't think it'd be that
big a deal it's good if we voted on the
heisman after the bowl season would we
have a different winner this year yeah
you asking me to predict the outcome of
the Orange Bowl
I guess because that's the key to that
question yeah I don't think you should
do it after the bowls I like the fact
that it's regular season I don't think
you should heavily weight things towards
guys into playoffs you know I think it's
about the season and always has been I
know there'll be different winners over
the years quite a lot of them that they
voted after the bowl games but but it's
not about one game it's about twelve
thirteen games and it in a regular
season for me so I would I wouldn't
change that part of it I might do some
other things to change I might then why
the the voting base in the Heisman vote
them to vote after the last weekend's
like 10% of the people sent the ballots
in Greece really I don't think it had a
big impact on the outcome a matter of
fact 90 percent came in afterwards it's
not bad but yeah I think the body could
use some tweaking but I don't think it
should be done after the bowls
I really don't who's the former Heisman
winner who's the real character who
shows up
yet if we owe you a blazer on
interlocked oh you red white and I crept
from the word go he was yelling boomer
sooner which I am he's excited but it
kind of belongs to Tyler Murray didn't
look it was kind of Baker's moment last
year but yeah Billy Billy get a little
excited and you standing up there along
with the past winners behind Murray he's
just having a dialogue no it wasn't on
Mike necessarily but I can hear it did a
hell of a job of blocking it out and you
can tune out crowd noise because he was
he had a guy right behind well is
encouraging but he was you know take
your time take your time you went out a
Billy you went out to Ohio State and
what yesterday give me a sense of
what it's like to be around urban even
though this is you know urban is closing
things out here he was a little bit at
peace I hate to say that because when
the game gets closer if you know Dan
he'll get it cranked up he desperately
wants to win that game
very very important for him to to get a
W and walk off but the Rose was first
ever visit there visited once he told me
what he was recruiting la a long time
ago but it was a lot and it wouldn't let
amenities in the park at the exterior
inside the first time yeah and it's
sweet way to wrap up your Ohio State
career we talked about a lot of things
you know he talked about his future the
fact that people don't believe he won't
coach what his critics will think you
know a couple regrets over the years of
games and players it got away so it's a
well-rounded I found it to be any good
peace of mind a very different that he
was during the season when I thought he
was in in pain I thought he was in
discomfort I thought he was in anguish
on the sidelines at times not enjoying
the four hour battery it's supposed to
be all about if you can't get joy and
satisfaction with a win and you put all
that time into four hours on Saturday
you know that's that's empty and I think
it was a rough roster for him not making
him out to be a victim because I don't
think he is but I think that you know
the health concerns are real if you
don't believe that did you send it on
you did you have Tom against the guy
because he was dealing with with the
doctors use the word risk and now it's
not just okay I'm uncomfortable I got a
headache I got to deal with that now
it's a risk to continue and I asked him
did you go out on your own terms because
he did make the decision but it's a
health thing so is that really on his
own turf though he felt he did he
doesn't think he's going to coach and
he's honest about that but it doesn't
you know he's never gonna say never so
did continue to the people who think
that he'll jump back I think he's gonna
just a teaching they get back into some
broadcast and will stay around the game
he hopes to find things it'll be
fulfilling he knows next year is gonna
be very very tough it's gonna be
uncomfortable when you get through that
first year that's what Bob Stoops told
them
it'll be fun here coming up next couple
of weeks tell Herbie we set a low Cris
hope the family's great and good luck
same to you Dan Merry Christmas
everybody they're all the dinettes Thank
You bud that Chris Fowler ESPN host
play-by-play voice of college football
and the mothership for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
[Music]